[Music]
from the outset of western thought
thinkers have argued about whether the
world is fundamentally static or in flux
this is no mere philosophical debate
the extraordinary success of science is
founded on the notion that unchanging
laws universal laws underlie everything
yet now
based on the investigation of ancient
quasar light and the x-ray properties of
distant galaxies leading scientists are
challenging this central idea and
proposing that the very laws of the
universe might change
are unchanging laws the only way to
understand the universe or do we need a
radically new framework to make sense of
a universe in flux
and if we were to accept changing
universal laws would we not require
unchanging laws that explain those
changes themselves
well now to our speakers lee smolin on
the screen here is a revolutionary
theoretical physicist he received his
phd from harvard in 1979 and has since
authored several books including
einstein's unfinished revolution time
reborn and the trouble with physics
sabina hossenfelder is a theoretical
physicist who specializes in the
foundations of physics she's a research
fellow at the frankfurt institute for
advanced studies where she leads the
superfluid dark matter group sabino is
also the author of lost in math how
beauty leads physics astray which
explores the concept of elegance in
fundamental physics and cosmology
paul davies is a world-renowned
physicist and best-selling author he
works on the big questions of existence
ranging from the origin of the universe
to the origin of life and from the
nature of time to the foundational
questions in quantum mechanics
so we're going to begin um by i'm going
to begin by asking the three speakers to
address briefly uh their position on the
central question that we're aiming to
address here and then we'll get into the
more general discussion so if i could
ask you each uh to uh address this
question are the laws of are the laws
that govern the universe fixed or might
they change over time um paul can we
kick off with you but yes and we're
going to kick off by am i pressing this
i'm limited three minutes uh
it might i think is correct uh the
notion of fixed laws
actually is something of a hangover from
theology the foundation
of physics uh three and a half centuries
ago doesn't mean the pixels are wrong
but it does mean that maybe the time has
come for us to
re-evaluate whether
fixed laws are the best way of
organizing
facts about the world or are there other
ways of organizing it
could the laws of physics change with
time we're going to be discussing that
but i wanted to throw in
two
ways that is not normally discussed in
that context
and the first of these
is that
the computational view of the universe
that nature is really
performing a gigantic computation
rather than infinitely precise abstract
platonic mathematical laws that it's
really more of a computation raises the
question about whether the computational
resources of nature are limited whether
there are things like rounding errors
involved and what this would mean is not
so much of the laws would change with
time but there'd be some flexibility or
error or uncertainty in the laws like
we're used to in the case of quantum
mechanics uncertainty in the states so
that's
one possibility that maybe the laws
don't so much change over time but
become sharper over time
the other is that i don't think figs law
is a very good fit to biology biological
systems undoubtedly
are dynamic
there are patterns and regularities but
the concept of open-ended evolution is
not something
that really
fits in well with the notion of fixed
laws
and
the last thing i want to throw in is the
possibility that the laws
of physics
might
not so much change with time as change
with the complexity of a system and i
considered in some of my research the
possibility of
laws which become
functions of the state of the system so
it's the states change in standard
physics laws are fixed but the states of
the world change with time
but if the laws
are functions of the state then that
gives you pathways to complexity which
we have simply haven't considered before
and i think that might be a better fit
to biological systems so uh and the last
last point i've got 30 seconds uh is
that when it comes to cosmology the
notion of a law
is something a little peculiar because
the law by definition applies to a class
of systems and if there's only one
universe what does it mean to say that
there is a law for that universe now
there may be more than one universe
we'll get into that a little bit later
on i've run out of time i can stop there
thank you paul
brilliantly timed slovenia
so
i think when we asked
whether the laws of nature like govern
the universe are fixed or changed over
time we have to first ask what laws are
we even talking about so we do have some
laws of nature that describe the
universe so that's a quantum field
theory in the standard mode of particle
physics and general relativity and those
don't change in time
so to that extent i would say our best
current description of the universe just
doesn't have this property now of course
one can generalize
the theories that one currently
that we currently use
and ask whether it agrees with
observations so if we make them time
dependent
what would be the observational
consequences and do we see any evidence
for that and to my best knowledge the
evidence is just no so it just doesn't
describe what we see
and also i mean this is the point which
has been made very many times um if we
would have a new law that is time
dependent that would also be a law right
um so
there would have to be a law for that
time dependence
so
it's kind of a circular question what do
we even mean by a time dependent law
so
this is why for me
the more interesting question is whether
the type of law that we currently use in
the foundations is really the right one
so the laws that we currently use they
all work the same way we we do have a
specification of an initial state at one
particular time that's basically all the
information about the system that there
is to be classical mechanics it would be
the momentum and position of the
particles and then we have what's called
an evolution law that tells us if we
feed in this initial state we can
calculate what happens at any later time
and it's an interesting question to ask
why do all the fundamental laws of
nature have this form and i think it's
just because that's the way that we make
experiments we prepare something in an
initial state and then we observe it
and see what happens and then we're
looking for an equation that describes
what we observe and i think that's why
we're using these differential equations
a lot but that doesn't mean that this is
fundamentally the best way to go about
it
which brings up the question like could
it be that there are entirely different
types of laws of different form not this
kind of differential equation that would
actually be more useful to describe our
observations
thank you lee it's time to bring you in
and i'll just remind you of the the
question uh we're asked to address here
are the laws that govern the universe
fixed or might they change over time
philip i've been thinking about that
question since the
mid-1980s so don't worry i'm not going
to forget it
it's a great honor to be here with my
friend sabine and paul
who i've known for a long time and been
discussing these things for a long time
my thought and i will address the
question of the med law is how could
they not
how could they not
if we want to explain the laws and i
know that you each will come back with
something
but
i have new things to say and let's get
to the new things we have to say i'll
start with the thing i always say
which is to quote charles sanchez purse
who said that when you explain a system
by referencing the laws
that's not the end of the explanation
you have to we must explain how the laws
came to be and why there are these laws
and not other laws and he goes on to say
this is 1893
in the architecture of theories that the
only scientific explanation which could
in a scientific that is testable manner
explain to us why these laws are not
others is if the laws have a dynamical
process
of evolution and i'll give you an
example
so that this is not something mysterious
um it's an idea i invented called the
principle of precedence
the idea is
well first of all why do we think that
the laws don't change imagine we prepare
a quantum system we let it evolve and
then we do a measurement to find out
which final state
is emerging
and we're not we can talk about quantum
mechanics
as well
if if there is a time independent law
that question to the universe generates
some probability distributions sometimes
if you start and state x it goes to
state
up or to stay down with certain
probabilities
we could reproduce that with a very
simple although silly sounding law that
simply says if you're
a
part of the universe an atom or
some system and you're asking what
happens next look to the ensemble of
past situations of the same
specification and pick one randomly
and that will reproduce exactly
all the complicated laws now you can say
oh that's real you're being really silly
how is a
system in quantum systems going to know
what all of its precedents are but there
are equally silly questions we go right
by all the time
like how does an electron know to obey
the electron part of the standard model
law and not the quark part of the
neutrino part
so
i
am convinced that the way forward
in physics is first of all
to and this took me years and years to
get my head straight against if we're
going to talk about laws evolving we
have to talk about a universe where time
is not only real but dynamical and
active
and in some sense creating the events
as time goes on in the creation
of events
is what time is
thank you yes and lee i hope we'll have
time to get more into some of those
ideas later because it's very hard to
condense them into three minutes um but
to kick off the discussion i i think we
ought to sort of start with the basics
and ask what even is
a scientific law i mean scientists you
know talk a lot about laws um we you
know you might remember hooke's law from
school from school well that can be
broken so you know what is it reminds me
of the the cartoon of policemen hanging
on to a guy who's floating up in the air
and saying i'm arresting you for
breaking the laws of physics you know
where when do we when can we break the
laws and when are they meant to be
inviolable so let's uh think about what
is a law of physics and sabino if we can
start with you
i always get
the most difficult questions
so
so i mean
you you can look for example just a
terminology like what what is it that
physicists actually call a law like we
have uh hubble's law uh hooke's law you
already said
this so this makes me think what
physicists call a law
is any kind of regularity that we
observe in nature
and that we can formulate
using mathematics but
there are also some things that i think
should be called a law following this
logic but they are not for example
schrodinger's equation why is it not
called shooting us law
i have no idea or the friedman equations
it's the same thing why are they not
called a law
so
i don't know like if i had to write down
a definition i would say uh it's
an an observed regularity um written
down in mathematics
okay thank you paul what's your take on
well well it's true it's a sort of
sloppy definition and when people ask
for an example of a law i think well
what about newton's law of gravitation
the inverse square law if you're twice
as far away the gravitational pull is
one quarter and so on seems very easy
and
i mean it's correct as far as it goes
but it's subsumed within einstein's
general theory of relativity it's more
encompassing better description of
gravitation it's a it's an approximation
in that theory
and then
during my career uh there's been this
huge movement towards the unification of
physics so the laws you find in the
textbooks on my bookshelf
in my office uh are not
the last word uh and the hope is that
there will be some sort of final
invaluable super law uh which would be a
formula you wear on your t-shirt and
that would be it that would be the
ultimate law and all the others are
approximations to it
um but sabine is absolutely right why
you know why do we not have
schrodinger's law and the one i like to
quote the other way is ohm's law
uh applies to electric circuits but you
know was owned law valid in the big bang
or something there were no electric
circuits uh and so uh you know the cons
the very concept of law but i just want
to throw in one point as i've got your
attention uh there's a lot
you learn at school
the law of conservation of electric
charge and it illustrates the point i
was making earlier
what does that mean what is a strict
interpretation of the law of
conservation of electric charge it means
an electric charge cannot
change and you think cannot change by a
little bit you know
tiny little bit teeny weeny little bit
the the strict reading of that is uh
it's an infinitely precise statement so
there's zero change that's what you're
supposed to believe but that's
completely untestable there's no way
that we can ever you know infinity is an
abstract concept it's useful in
mathematics and it makes calculations
simpler but we can never measure an
infinity or a zero and so making laws
infinitely precise
is an act of faith and that's why i say
perhaps we should consider sort of
fuzzy laws flexible laws uh the where
the fuzziness might be a function of
time
okay and lee in coming to you i wonder
if we could um uh
zero in on on the question i think we've
touched on it already of perhaps there's
a question here of what are the laws
supposed to be governing and i'm
thinking in particular
i'm with you
yeah yeah sure
um
the
what sabina was referring to and paul
when she said that
the laws always have the same framework
that's what i call the new tuning and
paradigm of the newtonian framework as
sabine has said fixed space of possible
states
which is also the fixed state of
possible initial conditions and a time
independent dynamical law that moves
them forward
um in work with roberto mangabera unger
and a book about five years ago we
explained and this is really the crucial
point
that such a law could only be applied
meaningfully to a small subsystem of the
universe
what there are several reasons why that
is one of them
is you test such a law's validity by
starting out with different initial
conditions and showing that the same
evolution law indeed does govern in
testable ways different initial
conditions and to have systems with many
different initial conditions of course
they have to be a small part of the
universe
so that's what i understand that's a
kind of law a law that governs a very
small part of the universe we're very
good at that we live in a small part of
the universe we look around we see other
small parts of the universe like other
galaxies and so forth which seem to be
obeying pretty much the same laws but if
we ask
what kind of law
selects those local laws those laws of
small regions what kind of law governs
the cosmological questions we want to
ask like what shows the laws and what
shows the initial conditions
that must be a law of a very different
kind
and it must be have a different
methodology
and different formulation and i can come
back later and explain but if we don't
get that distinction between a law of a
small part of the universe which only
makes sense
if it's applied to many small subsystems
and differentiate that
from
hypotheses about the universe as a whole
we did we don't get started so
let's keep that distinction in mind
okay okay thank you well um
it's time to move on to to the next
theme that i want to explore which is
whether
unchanging laws are actually necessary
for understanding the universe or
whether um you know we we can embrace
the notion that they change and if they
do what is governing that change but
before we get into that i wonder whether
we ought to just spend a little time
motivating why we're having this
discussion at all why is there why are
people thinking that perhaps the laws
that are thought to be fundamental might
change and paul i wonder if you could
talk a little bit about what has
motivated this challenging of you know
the notion that there are these sort of
fundamental unchanging laws
you mentioned about the quasar light and
are you referring there to the work of
john webb uh which i can say something
about uh uh
well about the possibility of the fine
structure yes exactly you see which is a
slightly different thing perhaps because
there it's talking about whether the
fundamental constants
are
but that's so it's still part of the
law-like nature so it would be nice to
think about that that distinction or if
it exists so yeah
so let me just deal with that first
because it's a contentious issue but it
illustrates the sort of difficulty um so
a part of the panoply of the the laws of
physics are that there are certain
parameters
these are numbers which you have to
measure we don't know why they are what
they are but my favorite is called the
fine structure constant and it's made up
by combining the charge on the electron
planck's constant and the speed of light
and it has the number it comes out to be
a pure number one over one three seven
nearly it's not exact and so uh if the
aliens are out there measuring these
things doesn't matter whether they've
got base 20 uh arithmetic or anything of
that sort they'll come up with the same
number basically the same number
and so there's a universal constant
we can't derive that number from any
known physics i've spent a lot of my
career thinking how we might be able to
do that but nobody's done it so we don't
know why it is what it is but it's
supposed to be fixed and then
a few years ago uh astronomical evidence
uh some of it collected by my old friend
john webb at that time at the university
of new south wales in sydney
um
he looked at the spectra of quasars so
these are compact highly luminous
objects sort of right out there so we're
looking back at uh
billions of years ago
and so we're seeing physics as it was
billions of years ago
and there's a slight hint not much more
than that that there's been a change in
that number what that one over 137
almost has changed very slightly uh
maybe a little little sort of glitch in
that number very contentious but if it
were correct if it was confirmed then it
would show
that the laws of electromagnetism and or
quantum mechanics you know something is
shifting there or had shifted you know
maybe you don't have to have sort of
continuous shift it could be a glitch it
can be a certain thing it may be a
function of the universe in some way we
don't know uh and it may all go away
but it relates to exactly the point i
made earlier
because the law of conservation of
electric charge is also the law of
conservation of that number if you fix
the speed of light and uh planck's
concept of quantum mechanics so if that
were to change you know it's an example
of
the lack of precision when you say
exactly
fixed
electric charge
your question i felt it was
why are we thinking about these things
and for me i've always thought about in
connection with cosmology because as i
said it is only one universe maybe it's
got different rules from everything else
but for me i've got really interested in
in
biological systems and whether there's
new physics lurking in living matter and
when you try to apply fixed laws of
physics to living matter it's just not a
good fit it's not a good way of
approaching it doesn't mean those laws
are broken but they're just not very
useful
and that what we really need is a new
conceptual framework for dealing with
those systems particularly with the
open-ended evolution as i said earlier
so that's why i'm thinking about these
things at this particular time okay
thank you
um sabina i have the sense from what you
said initially that you've you maybe
feel that there are some
laws as far as we know them at the
moment that aren't up for grabs there
are going to be fundamental perhaps
general relativity is one of those is
that your position do you feel that we
actually there must be
unchanging laws that are governing the
universe somehow
um no i i don't think so um i mean i i
think i'm fairly open-minded you know
what whatever works uh
works so the question was the unchanging
laws necessary for us to describe the
universe
i don't know but they're certainly
useful i mean we we know this already so
for example this evidence that
paul was just talking about with the
quasars i'm not terribly excited about
it i mean it's it's cool that they are
making these observations and
all of that but
in cosmology there are right now there
are so many tensions you know between
observations that don't really fit into
the current paradigm that makes me think
we're we're close to seeing a major
reorganization of this whole uh
framework and it god knows what happens
with this particular thing you know
maybe it may just go away
with with the re-analysis of the data so
i have actually i have two reasons to
think about different types of laws uh
one of which is what leo already said so
if we look at the universe as a whole
and we're trying to understand where it
came from
then really the the laws that we
currently use general relativity and um
quantum field theory
it doesn't really help us all that much
because they always need this initial
state right and then you can always ask
well where did this initial state come
from well it came from an even earlier
state and where did this come from so it
becomes this chicken and egg problem and
to really solve this problem you need an
entirely different type of law for
example the kind of law that lee was
talking about that evolves
but the other reason i've been thinking
about it is
it comes from
quantum mechanics and i'll take two
minutes try to explain why this
intrigues me so in quantum mechanics we
have
a lot of observations of weird
experiments that you've probably heard
about you know people always say quantum
mechanics is strange and you can't
understand it it's something with
schrodinger's cat and that kind of thing
um but
if it's it's quite easy at least i find
it easy to make sense of all this
supposed quantum witness if you allow
the state in the future to play a role
for the evolution of the system
and i know a lot of people think i'm
really really crazy for saying something
like this but if you think of something
like the double slit experiment
where you're preparing your initial
state say it's a beam of electrons and
it hits the two slits and it creates an
interference pattern okay so fine you
would say
so single electrons can interfere with
themselves
okay but then when you try to find out
which slit did the electron go through
the interference pattern vanishes and
why is that it kind of seems like the
electron knows what's going to happen
and you can actually
choose
what you measure after the electron has
already left
your your
gas whatever
so
how can this be
and if you
allow
the evolution of this electron beam to
depend on what will be measured suddenly
it all makes sense
but you can't describe a time of
illusion like this using the laws that
we currently have
so for me this is um the other reason to
take this seriously
um lee i think this would be a good time
for to if you can say a little more
about the idea that you've proposed
which is that if i'm going to put it too
crudely forgive me but that uh it is
conceivable that laws have emerged from
lawlessness that they are emergent
properties and that precedence has
something to do with that can you
explain that position
well i
i think i did and i'd like to
take that and go go a little bit further
in the direction i was going you see
that it fits together and thanks to
sabine
for for agreeing it's very unusual to
have some agreement with you
[Music]
that's beautiful
um
one of the things that i've been
thinking about
when i think about what a law on a
cosmological scale must do
is i reached the opposite conclusion of
many of our colleagues and it was really
roger penrose who first said this to me
that we should seek as much asymmetry as
much difference
as possible as we go down to the smaller
smaller scales
so with julian barber we invented a
measure
of the difference of the viewpoints
of the events in the universe and we
call this
variety
and it's a kind of measure of complexity
but particularly
it focuses on comparing the views to the
past
that different events have
and
it's a long story but to make it very
very short
um i
i found that i could derive
schroninger's equation or schrodinger's
law
if you like under the right
circumstances
from a positive law that the universe
makes sure
that there's as much variety as possible
which means the view from any two events
can be differentiated
so that's an example of a new kind of
law that has to be applied to the
universe as a whole and it has as a
consequence
schrodinger's equation in a certain
limit
and what's beautiful about it is it also
has as a consequence the corrections to
schroedinger's equation if we imagine
expanding in
the inverse of the square root of the
number of particles in a quantum system
and that may be testable and that i'm
very excited about
okay well thank you um i i i
want to uh think uh want us to talk now
about the question of um you know if uh
ideas like this prove to be the case or
if observations showed that actually
things do seem to have changed over time
the laws or fundamental constants
what would that imply
and i'm thinking um
for example that there's there is this
idea at the moment that we can seek to
understand the very early stages of the
universe ex by looking experimentally at
things that we can recreate through
particle collisions or however now
but if different laws applied back then
um that challenges that way of doing
science so i wonder um and lee if you
could uh begin by by talking a little
bit a bit about this if it turns out to
be the case if you're right or if even
you know it's a possibility we should
entertain that laws are not fixed that
they are
changing and have changed what does that
imply for
scientific practice and for the way we
think about science today
i think it implies that we must as venus
said
and paul said quite radically change our
view and one of the things
i think is that we have to get serious
about heisenberg and particularly get
serious about heisenberg and bragg and
freeman dyson and many people who said
that embedded in the quantum description
is the difference between the present
and the future
and the past
and that and this is
something that takes a long time to get
useful because it's not how we're used
to thinking that quantum mechanics
is built into the flow of time the flow
of moments
and treats the future the present and
the past
differently and in work with kelly of
their day we've been investigating some
pretty radical versions of this in which
there is no past there is no future
there is simply a present moment
made up of events that continue to
create each other so the picture we have
of the world as something that exists
deeply in time and we have to
explain why the laws a long time ago
were the same as the laws
now it goes away and the question
that we have to understand
in the work we're doing with faraday is
how the universe persists
why the universe as it's recreated
moment by moment
is similar to the universe that was a
future a few minutes ago well uh paul i
i
wonder if i could open that up to you uh
in particular if that is the case i mean
if ideas like this prove to be the case
it sounds pretty destabilizing for our
sense of science as it has traditionally
been of a search for universal truths
and perhaps for kind of eternal truths
but is that what science should be
looking for oh most of them don't
the sort of people i have coffee with do
but that's a you know a subset
and what lee is saying is
is of such enormous interest to me that
i'm not going to go there because
otherwise we'll we'll never
get out of this tent
because all this business about the
nature and flow of time
is dear to my heart
what i wanted to do was to say in
addition to you know are the laws
flexible or changing with time or not a
good way of organizing our data is to
throw in
uh new kinds of laws and there's a
couple
that i should mention because he really
goes into this whole discussion
um
the law
i don't know how much
physics here people know
but uh it's been said a couple of times
this morning that the laws are only part
of it if you want to
throw a ball in the air you've got a
sort of law of the parabola that's fine
but you won't know which parabola unless
you specify the initial conditions
the
angle and the speed of
throwing it and that's uh true of all of
the dynamical laws and sabine was
mentioning differential equations and
you have to have initial conditions for
those so come to the universe what were
the initial conditions of the universe
the big bang was remarkably uniform
why was that well we don't really know
and so you sort of assume that alongside
the laws say lack of gravitation that
might apply to the universe you then
have to specify the initial conditions
but
many years ago uh jim hartel and stephen
hawking came up with a proposal which
was i won't go into it in detail but it
was effectively a law of initial
conditions so you've got all the laws of
physics we don't know where they come
from
uh or why they have the form that they
do and whether they change with time
that's the other thing so it's all a
mystery why not throw in a law of
initial conditions as well don't know
where it comes from but you posit that
is you know maybe a law of initial
simplicity uh and so they they had a
particular proposal it was motivated by
quantum mechanics don't need to get into
it but you know can we should we
consider that particularly in cosmology
a law of initial conditions as well as
dynamics of the universe
and there's another example
of a law that
it's not scientifically respectable but
it was cooked up between
the wolfgang paoli the physicist
and jung
the uh psychologist psycho analyst um
and it was uh an a causal connecting
principle it's called synchronicity and
people often refer to this if there are
coincidences
and it's usually in science to say these
uh coincidences are just coincidences
it's not anything deeper but imagine
we've got a space time as a big map time
this way space subway and we've got all
these events
and our laws govern
what happens as the universe evolves as
we've been discussing
and it's limited by the speed of light
so what happens over there and what
happens here
can only affect each other causally if
light has time to go between them but
what if there's a law
outside of that it would lead to strange
patterns in space-time which would not
be captured by those laws we can't rule
that out
that so what happens here might depend
on something that that happens
sabine was saying it you know in the
future over there you can't you can't
rule those out those sorts of patterns
so this is just enlarging what we might
consider if we're going to
put all of this in the melting pot i'm
not suggesting any of this is actually
correct but we must be open to it well i
think what what's uh striking in recent
years is how
quite aside from whether the laws that
we observe are unchanging or not it
seems to be
a bit more respectable let's say at
least to suggest that there may be other
universes that have entirely different
laws that our laws may not be at least
unique um
and sabina i wonder if you could comment
on whether you find that a useful thing
to suppose given how difficult it is to
prove or disprove or investigate
well so i i was about to answer the
question but now you ask a different
question
so about the multiverse i mean is it
useful i mean i would say to some extent
it's useful as a kind of thought
experiment like we we can write down
different laws and we can ask well what
would a universe look like
you know that was a little bit different
uh what would happen is it useful to
actually describe the observations in
our universe i would say no so from a
scientific perspective you know
to explain observations i don't think so
it but it does have some use say to get
to know our theories better i would
acknowledge this but if i may you know
i would like to i would like to um add a
point to the question what what
difference would it make like what what
would what could we learn from it um if
we develop new laws and um one point
paul already said
um is
that we may have this weird influence
from the future or from very different
parts of the universe actually which i i
totally understand people think it's
crazy but
it might actually help to explain some
things that we observe for example the
measurement process in quantum mechanics
but also and this is something which
david deutsche has been working on and
i i also put lee's cosmological natural
selection in that area it might turn out
that we're wrong to
look for more fundamental laws by way of
reductionism ontological reductionism
looking at shorter and shorter distance
scale which is kind of this route that's
driven by building bigger and bigger
colliders
because it it may be to use this example
from cosmological natural selection that
the laws come about by
optimizing a particular macroscopic
property and in in these theory that's
the number of black holes in the
universe which is it's not a fundamental
thing you know black holes are not
elementary particles but it's definitely
a well-defined quantity and
if you can show that the constants of
nature happen to be so that they
maximize the number of black holes in
the universe that's predictive you can
calculate something from it so i find
this very intriguing and david deutsch
is kind of making a similar point when
he
argues for example that the laws of
nature have to be so that they can give
rise to turing machines so to particular
types of universal computers that tells
you something about the properties that
the laws of nature must have
but it's not a statement about the tiny
little particles
right thank you lee if i could come to
you
again on this question and um i'm struck
in particular by what both you and
sabine have said about how
these issues
seem to point towards the potential to
tell us something about time
you know so what we're talking about
here is not oh the laws change over time
but actually that unchanging laws might
the changing laws or evolving laws
might actually give us some insight into
what time is in the first place
yes
one very important aspect of that
which we worked on with marina cortez
for a long time
what is the question of whether
time is reversible if
time is something dynamic
as i mentioned which creates moments
upon moments upon moments is that
if that's fundamentally what the world
is
we posited that it was not reversible
and then we of course have a lot to
explain because many of the laws on the
intermediate scales like
electromagnetism
are reversible
another thing to come to your question
about multiverses
we found it within the work with marina
very important to
assume that there is only one universe
and that
has consequences
for the ways those systems
evolve and i i it's a little bit too
complicated to explain that here
but i don't know if the postulate of
many universes
is helpful i i had a version of it as
well
but the postulate that there is only one
universe seems to me very fruitful and a
question pops into my mind lee um that
if uh laws have evolved and are emergent
in this way is there anything inevitable
about that could we have ended up uh
evolving different laws just as
evolution is contingent
um that's a very very interesting
question i don't i certainly don't know
enough
and i hear i follow paul
and also recently my colleagues molina
and andrew and stu kaufman
in using biology not just to fit biology
into physics but as paul has been doing
and sarah for some time
at your center to use biology as an
example
of how we're to think
of these kinds of questions
that's that's a really interesting
perspective that biology can be useful
to physics and not just the other way
around
and by thanking the speakers the
panelists
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv